What we've written expresses a single constraint,
that is a single property of the system which must always ho,
hold. Okay? It happens to be an invariant as indicated by the INV, keyword.
What, one thing that I've glossed over is, the fact that,
we use the numbers 2 and 3, explicitly. Without any indication that they're,
they're dates. Now that can be inferred from the type of checkout.
But if we were to get this completely right,
we have to make sure that all the types matched up.
And in fact, we were talking about two weeks here or three weeks here. We do
have a date class but we have to make sure that we're using it appropriately.
Each OCL constraint is interpreted in the context of a particular class.
What that means is that any names that occur without qualification.
That means without having only a single part without any period in there
are interpreted in the context of a particular class. And
what that means is that the name could be the name of the class,
it could be the name of an attribute, or it could be the name of an operation.
We're also allowed within the language to refer to elements of other classes.
And in that case, we're going to have to explicitly name the class. And
then put a period separator. And then the name of the attribute or
the name of the operation in the other class. Those are qualified names. But
if we're doing it in, if we're referring to names that belong with the class
itself, we don't have to which is why we have the context keyword.
This particular constraint is conditional and says that for each book object,
if the bestseller attribute of that object is true, then the checkout period
attribute for that object must have the value of 2. Denoting two weeks,
otherwise the checkout period attribute must have the value if 3